harry caul quand j'étais petit c'est
caché sur le lit pour fumer en cachette
une chute libre
il se profile et sans un bruit à la fin
de la nuit certains d'entre eux fument
et même dans les toilettes
le privilège qu'ils accordaient c'est
toi le petit qui craquent est une
allumette pour l'heure
vim
j'entends la voix dire qu'elles ont
accumulés
si tu devines révisé dans mon coche je
te frappe
moi j'ai fumé beaucoup plus tard lorsque
j'ai vu un point vous gâte
pincet endroits célèbres silhol
identique est assez aux marcheurs ou
dans le doute
identifiée à toute heure
quel droit tu n'a connu que des déboires
du rentrée un sens le sens sans la
moindre féminine conquête les gens ton
de voix
oh